Senate Republicans are trying to bridge
differences over the latest version of
their health care bill health care is
one of the issues CBS News contributor
Frank Luntz discussed discussed with a
bipartisan group of Congress members the
group included three senators and nine
representatives six were Democrats
and six were Republicans the
wide-ranging conversation included a
discussion about the ongoing Russia
investigation I have to raise one issue
because it's timely it's the issue of
Russia and what we are learning what
should we know and what don't we need to
know I think we all have bipartisan
support and respect for Bob Mueller
furthermore in the Justice Department he
has the utmost integrity it's in his
hands he will do a thorough
investigation I have every confidence in
that investigation but I will tell you
that I think most of us in this room
agree that there should be a consequence
to Crimea being annexed Ukraine being
invaded the Russian Russians interfering
in our democracy and we will have Frank
a Russian sanctions a Russian sanctions
bill sanctions bill against Russia on
the floor of the house I hope in the
very with what the Chairman just said
raise a house so we have action on
Russia we have bipartisanship well the
only person who disagrees with the
Chairman is the president and while he
disagrees with it he's running down NATO
he's running down the European Union and
Putin couldn't ask for a better friend
than that that's become too much of an
issue as to what our real job is and if
we're not looking at some well to make
this economy dynamic and robust again
and getting people back to work if we're
more concentrating on the Russians
interfering with our elections as
opposed to the Russians interfering with
our economy right now and that's turning
away from our real job of getting people
back to work seeing wages rise again
seeing families be able to be together
understand look we saw them here week
after week after week with respect week
after week after week and do nothing we
don't pass any legislation we don't walk
and chew gum at the same time the
American people expect us to do that the
Russians attacked our elections we need
to respond to
Russians and we need to do the work
you're talking about on the economy we
need to do both let's take the issue of
health care the Republicans demonized
Obamacare and the Democrats are
demonizing the Republican legislation is
that the way we should be discussing
what may be the most important issue you
will deal with this year some of us
probably have philosophical differences
I believe that if you live in America
you've got a right to affordable quality
health care and I think probably
everybody agrees on that value and the
difference is how do you get us there I
can speak recently there was no outreach
to Democrats in the house to work
together so it wasn't a matter of saying
here's what we're doing and you're
either on board he or not there was not
a significant meaningful effort made
from the beginning saying hey let's put
our heads together and try to work this
out
the challenge that we hear on these
issues these juglar issues is a
Republican alternative or a Democrat
solution the American people aren't
concerned about labels they want to know
about their health care people want to
know what are my co-pays how do I take
my child to the doctor what does it look
like if I can't afford it if we're not
answering those basic questions and if
we cannot find a point to rally around
it's our fault so the next big issue is
gonna be tax reform are we gonna get it
is there gonna be any bipartisanship
there right now I don't see it happening
I don't see it happening a lot of big
issues out there we need to address we
need to respond to business some of the
business taxes corporate taxes so you've
set a litmus test already and it has
neither donor and begun to be but isn't
that the problem you're talking about
okay so in principles of philosophical
principles that we have so I think a lot
of us would agree tax code needs to be
simplified you guys are absolutely that
no question yes grease that you need to
simplify that okay so maybe we can get a
full of senators responding in my
question this is really cool I got a day
candless function absolutely I think the
point is about having respect and here
in this body in Congress yes it stems
from having relationships it stems from
having an authentic respect for our
colleagues whether we agree or disagree
on one issue or almost all issues
because that's that's that's what people
want from Washington and Franklin's
joins us now from Providence Rhode
Island Frank good morning a Gallup poll
has the approval of Congress right now
at 20% anything you heard yesterday to
indicate that there is room for progress
on any of these ideas yeah there are two
members that you didn't include in that
clip that said very important things
Senator Joe Manchin from West Virginia
talked about not campaigning against his
colleagues that how can you govern in a
non election year if you are attacking
people in an election year and attacking
them personally and several of those
people there said you know what that's a
great idea
and Brian mast the new Congress and the
freshman from Florida talked about the
sacrifice of armed services of our men
and women in uniform and how members of
Congress need to understand and
appreciate that sacrifice and how they
need to work together just like our
armed services do will you put aside all
differences because you have one mission
I have to acknowledge you guys focused
on the issues but for most of the
conversation they talked in principals
and for the most part these Democrats
and these Republicans do agree and they
talked about how the media took sound
bites to focus on where they disagree
rather than what unifies Frank
principles are very important no one
doubts that but the bottom line is they
have to come together on the issues and
they're not but if you focus only on the
differences and you have that vote that
you're showing right there we didn't
focus on the differences they also they
could come together on on Russia and and
but there are other issues I just don't
think it's appropriate to constantly
focus on where they disagree without
also acknowledging like Russia and there
are other issues that they talked about
where these people these men and women
are doing the best they can
to find common ground when their
constituents are all riled up when the
country is seriously polarized all
Congress is is a reflection of the
American people and I ought to know
because that's what I'm doing every
single day across the country much of it
for CBS Frank Harry and it go ahead how
are they doing the best they can let's
say let's let's get off of Russia for a
second and talk about health care one
recent poll shows it as the lowest rated
passage of any sort of bill and in 30
years I mean you've got Republicans
who's in charge of everything in
Washington who can't get together and
and come up with a bill that has any
sort of approval rating amongst
Republicans and then you have the same
thing on the Democratic side the
Republicans demonized Obamacare as I was
going through the process Democrats are
doing exactly the same thing to the
Republicans I agree with you but if you
focused on Russia's you went right to
health care if you focused on Russia you
saw 12 out of 12 members said that the
investigation being conducted by the
former FBI director Mueller that that
investigation they will accept the
findings and in fact they want to wait
till that investigation is done all 12
members raised their hand and said yes
this is something we need to do and they
all support sanctions against Russia we
saw that that is a place where they came
together and that is pretty powerful but
you're focused on the place where they
came apart it's just interesting that I
would note that to you all an hour and
10 minutes
they agreed with more than they
disagreed with these aren't these aren't
trivial issues that we're focusing on
Frank well we appreciate your time in
the group thank you thank you